bene anche di ragazzi e benvenuti a
questa intro semplice perché se non a
youtube per semplice su youtube airline
perché su youtube her life si possono
fare intro timide oppure in tre
energiche io oggi ho scelto entro timida
e quindi buona visione
cos'è un panino ciao paride pensavo che
dopo tanto a registrare di tale forse ti
è venuto a farmi aumentato da mangiare
che se mia madre javier cui si mangia
bbx vincere a genova da registrare il di
tenere il d'italia subito per riprendere
a mangiare qualcosa dalla dormire
avete mandato del cibo va bene come lo
mangia mangia amiche posso vendere le
cose e fammi vedere uno di questi che
cazzo pieni al comune come pari a
girarsi nata da una per il santa città
ok ma io voglio giocare porca put a sei
presa nella g dormi mangia no non posso
fare perché devo faccia mangiare aspetta
una famiglia della quale mangio piccante
rennes per i saggi che ha piccante re
non va bene voglio mangiare perché so
non posso registrare che gioia
pienamente una volta in città qual è il
tuo nome caro mi chiamo fa vj e tu chi
sei susy sono proprietarie del piccante
rennes che posso mangiare e posso farti
una foto su instagram di tango dai
pubblica una foto con lei con da finirlo
fatta non si toccano mela voi mettervelo
fatta due volte
che cazzo fate ma cos'è ma cos'è ho
toccato l'ex in a una vecchia
piccante rehn susy show fame ho toccato
le cime a una vecchia
ma che cazzo sta giornate no vabbè
ragazzi incredibile poiché la sport dai
per favore momento trasporto vediamo via
ciao ragazzi è stato bello bellissimo e
comunque
giampiero poi ci sarebbero solo corsa la
funzione visione notturna donne gianpi è
marco polo già non facciamoci domanda
andiamo a casa e meglio o hanno smesso
di giocare non hanno smesso quello gioca
la sua guarda guarda che roba giocata so
ma che colpo di testa se ronaldinho
qualora incredibile c'è una mira
pazzesca fenomeno è un fenomeno che sta
fermo ma doveva 6 giocatore numero 1
rispetto paziente fare una foto hanno
giampiero non può scattare ma poi ma
gianpi quando ci sono le cose importanti
non sei scarico non scatti inutile
inutile inutile inutile pazzesco però a
volte jean pierre dormi ok perfetto o
234 iscritti però l'attenzione ma che
vado a dormire mi danno i soldi giovedì
4 ma su come fare le cose devo andare
dei cartelli dove c'è scritto proprio
play con ok adesso so ma ho capito la
ritardo dring buongiorno non te la do
ancora detto bel biglietto per i
festival costa 500 monete ma io sono uno
youtube è visto che il video non pone
titolo abbastanza c'è un altro modo per
guadagnare cose extra facendo dei
commissari per i tuoi vicini
incarichi va bene faccio il delivery
appena visti tuoi video caricare
letteralmente di sosterremo darwin
grazie darwin ciao darwin ciao
arrivederci non sei un pacchetto a susy
minchia velate presa bene ci ha toccato
mattina s'è presa bene che la noble e
non vuole il pacchetto vuole proprio
tutto lubac proteggo io di tutto questo
io registra une vidéo andrea fa la foto
col play con darei un pacco assisi che
non è mio ma è un pacco vero e di david
no cosa devo fare qui sono le tendenze
armorize nucleus non ce l'ho però degli
awards diciamo un gameplay salute
immediatamente mentre coach un anno al
timidamente scusate mettere gioco carica
fai un commento tecnico notaio taglio è
sita quando se lo carica tagli che cazzo
vuole un caricamento giochi per ridere 6
per fermare chiudi il video non lo fare
questo i tagli agli iscritti ragazzi
posso fermare il video se pozzo è grazie
ragazzi gentilissima perché poi anche
scartarle nelle piccole ho capito perché
evita video che ogni tanto ho detto
questo ok
12 che però non ci occupiamo gas
3 e 4 perfetto no e non li so più
montare vita non sono più abituato jean
una volta l'esperto adesso adesso no
pubblica immagine di copertina
questo cinque motivi il gameplay più
atteso dell'anno questo qui al mio
classico titolo proprio nel mio titolo
come va
ventun like ragazzi bellissimo va bene
allora andiamo a fare
soldi devo fare solo il mistero dei
soldi ma di solito 11 monete una merda
tutti giocatori giornata di play con
perché non credo che tutto su quello sì
ho capito adesso vado vado al play con
un'influenza ragazzi pazzesco come
influenzò io ne influenzano anche chiara
ferragni ragazzi non c'è soldi manco per
magnava dove cazzo ritrovo 500 euri per
andare al play con madonna al traffico
faccio una foto col play con porco del
demonio visto che
non ho soldi portatemi al play con
alimenti già lui gli hashtag che però in
uno dello scrivano male l'ho fatto ho
fatto play con ho mai notato l'auto
nuova tendenza è stata trattenuta ci
sono tenute che quando le scoprì vengono
trattenute preparano in altro tipo di
copione pubblica un gameplay con play
con che senso ma non so io a questo è il
play con al petto da settima il
ventottesimo giorno di primavera va bene
e io in un omaggio a play con play
studios 7 po mantendo cazzo faccio le
interviste l'intervista non sto male
questo poi risale dell'energia dai
giampiero per l'amore di cristo e fa
meno nobile olaf angolato senso mentre
l'energia non dà la colpa a me non mi
sembra neanche guardare inutile poiché
ragazzi veramente se vedete la mia vita
youtubers life ci ho fatto gli upgrade
nello studio della casa
ciò giampiero cioè pazzesca sta roba
solo che registro video anche se vorrei
mangiare che ho fame quindi diversità mi
dai 22 soul 22 panini amazin e il
proprietario e calypso
è da meno lui uster zh e o mi intendo
nel senso di wurstel nel senso di mangia
mangia dai mangia porca [ __ ]
ora possiamo fare i video di merda cioè
energia si pensò posso vendere no blog
blog io col mio amico james a no perché
non ho abbastanza energia giuste nella
data troppo poca o 18 manette però
avesse stimato a dormire [ __ ]
allora interagisci registra video
e hanno prodotto mettere aspetta devo
fare così ok watch che tieni e lo
conservo che è perfetta anche l'altro
non si fa brembo si tiene agli omessi
come solo scappare bellissimo
adesso possa registrare interagisci
registra video vai
jazz meno il kers celio gameplay walker
va bene gli inizi è bella a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a guardà cazzi
durante il tutorial madonna che bello
questi cats giochi per vivere spiego la
loro cioè la misera tempo
diciamo che ne so io magari salto
schiaccio hicks giampiero si sta
scaricando chiudi video
bene questo è un gran gameplay ceo
finalmente trovato il tuo cavallo di
battaglia works gameplay honey pie
studio swan
tutto ciò è il nostro video praticamente
tendenze catturate tutte
perché dovrei scartare certe cose non
capito
a scartare il video che venerano non
scartiamo e video che buono bottino che
tipo di play con non ho soldi e cast
devo tenere quanto non sono anche quando
quando scade sta roba
evita video che giampiero non fa niente
allora gameplay vai partiamo
134 ormai la testa perfetto editing due
punti bellissima l'anteprima
io vorrei mettere un anteprima del
gameplay ecco perché mi essere un fan di
onifai studio swan
cinque motivi per parlare di
kelis cats 12 e vado avanti like quando
parli valle si parla di cats sempre la
juve quando una brutta giornata niente
mi fa più felice di vedere un tuo video
non me ne perdono grazie della nei
veri grazie veramente un gentilissima un
messaggio grip
raggiungi la lega bronzo amica 10.000
iscritti ma come cazzo ci arrivò al 25
si va dai 25 25 esimo giorno c'è tempo
per arrivarci perdiamo in 35 si può fare
si può fare quindi ragazzi questo era il
video su youtube live vi ricordo come
sempre lasciare mi piace perché
giampiero si sta scaricando cioè al
prossimo video e schede al canale di
seguito vi su install ai ragazzi
[Musica]